hey guys this is Alana here just showing
you guys my own minecraft server I
haven't played on here in ages but um
friend just sent me all the old logs so
I just wanted to show you guys this
house that took me forever to build so
this is it this is the entrance to
rapture as I call it a little bit by our
shopkins buy it so you come down a lot
of here which I think it's really really
cool way to get into the water though
you get really buff arms know that
that's a bad thing
and then you end up in my little lobby
which is kind of like an art gallery
just really bad and pixelated and then
to the left here is my tree farm and
then my little jacuzzi so this is I
guess like the roof of my house where
you can just come hang out it's the
actual door come downstairs
dudu immediately is my living room so
this is made it faster and stone slabs
on the floor there and then we've got no
blocks for speakers and a huge TV which
I like to think is a fighting game not
sure which one but they have it this is
my kitchen here's my sink and then
you've got oven which i think is really
cool up trapped oh this is my fridge and
it's just a dispenser with an iron door
in front of it some relief and then it's
portion stuff making potions back out
here is my lovely dining table stand
stone and netherrack stairs another
brick rubber and weird painting I don't
know what that is and then here's my
study so we got bookcases here I try to
make the design a little bit different
from normal so I like that and then my
little table which would have a computer
if I could figure out how to emulate one
enchanting table I know they work better
if you got books around you but I don't
know I don't use it anymore I just
prefer the way it looks like that and an
awesome and an awesome ma fireplace back
out here we've got my pool table and a
bass or I quite like the bar actually um
it felt glowstone in the back there I'm
kind of proud of it
it looks pretty cool and then this is my
bedroom in here so just wool on the
floor he's a little lamp it's off and
the bed and stuff chests and he is a
common obviously nothing in it because
what would I put it it's on the chests
and then we have my TV in here on a
little cabinet
sorry it's obviously made of wool
thicker than the other one now here's my
personal bathroom so there's my little
scene
and then we've got like so no tables
benches to put stuff on another little
painting the toilet you flush it doesn't
do anything and then we've got the
shower the waters held in place by the
little stone there the pressure plate
and then a little place to wipe your
feet so I kind of like to show back out
here we have oh wait there's my mind
that I have an incident with a creeper
Leah that kind of blew it out so I'm
probably not going to show you guys that
and here is my nether portal it's
blocked off by an iron door because
sometimes song be Pigman get through
there but there's just some seats inside
there and there's no button so I just
hacked on the door usually because
making a button would mean having to get
rid of the glass because it doesn't go
on glass so that is my nether portal I
don't really go there anymore though
anyway in here we have my crops and
stuff well irrigated all my furnaces see
we're making got some stone in there
that's pretty sweet and then in here I
keep all my seeds and things and then
here's just food all I eat is wheat and
through here we've got my backdoor which
means stuff a lot easier when I was
renovating here in fact oh oh sorry
alright I just think the house is really
really cool from the outside especially
cuz you know it's all underwater it's
all bright and everything so that is
rapture it took me so long to build
because it takes forever to build on the
water but I'm really really happy with
it so thanks for checking it out